everything everywhere all at once is a
non-linear Thrill Ride that made some
confused viewers pull all of their hair
out all at once looking for answers
here's a handy Guide to the film's most
head scratching Concepts
after the basics of the film's
multiversal plotline are explained the
alternate Wayman has to extradite Evelyn
from a dangerous situation using
impressive and unexpected martial arts
prowess before doing so he retrieves a
tube of lip balm from his fanny pack and
choose it unlocking his abilities it
turns out that people who hop between
universes can access skill sets
possessed by alternate versions of
themselves by finding the universe where
a version of them knows how to do the
relevant task in order to make a
connection with whatever Universe the
necessary skills are from the user must
perform something random enough to
channel said universe's probability
wavelength at first these random events
are simple enough eating lip balm giving
yourself a specific number of paper cuts
and professing love for someone who's
trying to kill you or qualify but as the
film progresses the skills and the work
necessary get stranger and stranger
the process of hopping through universes
is delicate and takes a lot of time and
training to hone Evelyn is very new to
all of this and the circumstances do not
afford her the luxury of lengthy
instruction as such she fails early on
when she tries to access the universe
that can make her a better fighter
instead of gaining skills she
accidentally connects to a world where
everyone has long bendy cylindrical
fingers that are exactly as goofy as
they sound
[Music]
I cannot be the worst what about the hot
dog one as the film explains a
particular aberration causes each
Universe to Branch off on its own every
time Evelyn has shown one of these
branches she can see exactly where in
her life she moved away from the path
and created it but this particular
universe is hand waved away as being
inexplicable it's just a world where
somehow humans evolved to have hands
with hot dog fingers this is initially
played for laughs but in subsequent
scenes we return to this alternate world
where Evelyn is in a relationship with
an alternate version of Deirdre or IRS
auditor this big broad joke turns out to
contain real catharsis and a sweet
metaphor about how even in a world where
we have hot dogs for fingers we get
better at using our feet
one of the more straightforward
universes Evelyn encounters is the one
she draws the bulk of her martial arts
skills from it's a version of her life
where she never left China with her
future husband Raymond and wound up
meeting a teacher who relentlessly
trained her to be a skilled fighter she
became so talented in fact that she
moved to Hollywood and became a huge
movie star renowned for her work in
action films not unlike Michelle yeoh
herself at a point that the film's run
time that could reasonably serve as an
end point Evelyn dies and the credits
begin to actually roll they're the real
credits crediting the real filmmakers
which sells this moment is the saddest
ending to a movie imaginable before
pulling out to reveal that in the
Hollywood Evelyn timeline the movie
premieres she's been at this whole time
is for the movie we've been watching
which follows the main Evelyn's Journey
where's our daughter
this fake out Works incredibly well
because everything everywhere all at
once is longer than similar films its
faux ending is thus conceivable and all
the more so because the plot has already
seeded the Hollywood angle so well
in the Hollywood Evelyn Universe this
version of our heroine runs into the
women she hasn't seen since they broke
up on her youth she's astonished to see
him looking well having assumed he grew
destitute for financial failure in
America without her there to steer and
motivate him but this way man seems
healthy successful and strangely at
peace many of the alternate worlds
Evelyn has seen seem better than her own
she's happier in them because she didn't
get married didn't have a family and
didn't end up taking care of the father
who made her this way
but this universe plunges further into
the film's what if premise to show the
Folly inherent in its perspective it's
also one of the most important strands
of the film's tightly woven third act
because it's key to reminding Evelyn why
she fell for Wayman in the first place
even in a world where she abandoned him
he's still willing to give them another
shot because he loves her that much but
some viewers may be put off by the
seemingly strange way these sequences
are shot this movie maintains a
kaleidoscopic visual language that
encompasses a lot of tones to account
for multiple universes this sequence
however has more of its own style than
almost any other it is uniquely
melodramatic as some cinephiles will
notice it specifically calls to mind the
work of Wang car y particularly the
films in the mood for love and its
quasi-sequel 2046.
the biggest reveal of everything
everywhere all at once comes relatively
early on but the full scope of its
implications take a while to unpack at
first all we know about the existential
threat that is jobu tupaki is that they
were once someone who hopped between
universes like others from the alpha
world and that keeping too many
alternate realities together in one mind
caused them to crack soon after we
learned that jobu is Joy Evelyn's
daughter in the alpha World Evelyn the
first person to discover the
multiverse's existence pushed her
daughter harder and harder eventually
she lost herself and became a profoundly
powerful agent of chaos and destruction
[Music]
organic our Evelyn's initial forays into
verse hopping proved difficult because
all she sees are better versions of
herself in her life but with joy
experiences is more harrowing she can
see that in every world no matter what
dynamic forms between her and her mother
there is still suffering in confusion
she exists in infinite worlds and all of
them stink initially it seems like Joy
is obsessed with fine ending and killing
every Evelyn is Revenge but really she
wants to find one who will understand
her and see existence for what it is so
she doesn't have to struggle alone
jobu's Godlike ability showcase some of
the film's most fascinating and Visually
arresting ideas but the real magic is in
the emotional underpinning of her Arc
the over-the-top villain origin of Joy
being pushed too hard by her scientist
mother is suitable for the genre but
every infraction from every Evelyn onto
every Joy is portrayed as equally
cataclysmic our Evelyn's key betrayal
hiding Joy's sexuality from Evelyn's
father proves to be just as traumatic
and harmful as another Avalon
experimenting on her daughter until she
became a kind of anti-deady this is the
key to the film's exploration of
existence and generational trauma
[Music]